[Música]
en la habana a la capital de cuba el
hotel saratoga sufre una fuerte
explosión que habría dejado al menos
ocho fallecidos y más de diez personas
desaparecidas según autoridades locales
investigaciones preliminares apuntan a
un posible escape de gas
pero siguen los bombardeos rusos sobre
la sitiada planta de azov talent
mariupol según denunció el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr cell ski y las
evacuaciones avanzan además ucrania
lanzó una contraofensiva en dirección a
jarquín edición
amnistía internacional denunció que
rusia cometió numerosos crímenes de
guerra en la periferia de kiev y propinó
ataques indiscriminados contra civiles
en buche y boro dianca la organización
condenó los hechos y pidió que los
responsables sean juzgados analizamos en
esta emisión
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos esta
emisión con noticias que llegan desde la
habana el hotel saratoga de la capital
cubana sufrió una fuerte explosión que
provocó el derrumbe de parte del
edificio y de momento se registran al
menos 8 muertes investigaciones
preliminares apuntan a un posible escape
de gas que según el primer secretario
del partido comunista en la habana
habría dejado además unas 13 personas
desaparecidas el presidente miguel díaz
canel se hizo presente en el lugar de
los hechos y en el hospital donde son
atendidos los heridos los trabajos de
búsqueda y rescate avanzan en el hotel
donde todavía es posible que haya
personas atrapadas y el número de
víctimas mortales podría aumentar en las
próximas horas a lo largo de todas las
jornadas seguiremos muy atentos en
nuestros informativos al avance de esta
noticia
seguimos esta emisión con el avance de
la guerra en ucrania las tropas
ucranianas lanzaron una contraofensiva
en dirección a jarquín y zoom mientras
en la portuaria ciudad de mariupol las
evacuaciones continúan en medio de
ataques rusos cerca de 500 civiles ya
fueron retirados y 200 resisten en la
planta siderúrgica de austral junto a
los últimos soldados y ucranianos que ha
pedido ayuda a médicos sin fronteras
para evacuar más civiles de la planta y
asegura que el jueves no hubo tregua en
contra de lo anunciado el día anterior
por los rusos no obstante naciones
unidas envió un nuevo convoy para
evacuar a los civiles que seguían
atrapados en la fábrica
en mariupol el alto el fuego decretado
por los rusos no se cumplió el batallón
de azov denuncia sangrientos
enfrentamientos y acusó a moscú de
atacar a los civiles pero a pesar de los
combates el viernes se inició una nueva
evacuación de al menos 23 civiles y
hoy ha continuado la operación de
rescate de mariupol con la ayuda de la
onu y el comité internacional de la cruz
roja la gente está de camino a una zona
segura en total más de 150 personas de
'las hostal y más de 300 personas de
mariupol y sus suburbios han sido
evacuadas a través del corredor
humanitario esta semana comentaron el
corredor el presidente ucraniano también
acusa a los rusos de seguir bombardeando
la zona mientras que el kremlin lo niega
nuestro presidente y comandante supremo
el presidente putin ha dado públicamente
la orden de no lanzar un asalto a la
planta de asoex tal no se ha dado
ninguna otra orden
el jueves por la noche vladimir putin
dijo que el ejército ruso seguía
preparado para garantizar la evacuación
de los civiles al parecer todavía hay
200 refugiados en el complejo atrapados
entre los combates ucranianos tras más
de dos meses de asedio e intensos
bombardeos mariupol está casi
completamente destruida el presidente
volodymyr selenski dijo que sería
necesaria una versión moderna del plan
marshall para reconstruir la ciudad así
como todas las demás devastadas por la
guerra como hemos dicho unos 200 civiles
siguen dentro de la planta de acex tal
aún cuando durante el último cese el
fuego se consiguió evacuar a otros en
torno a 150 civiles junto a ellos están
también los últimos militares ucranianos
que defienden la planta nuestra enviada
especial a ucrania
catalina gómez ángela podido hablar con
algunas de sus mujeres que todos los
días se reúnen para intentar obtener
noticias de sus maridos en la medida que
pasan las horas mayores la atención
sobre lo que va a pasar con esas
doscientas personas y un número
indefinido de militares que se
encuentran atrapados en esos
los subterráneos de las heridas o total
que están siendo atacados con mayor
insistencia desde ayer por las fuerzas
rusas un grupo de mujeres de los
militares que se encuentran allí
atrapados van todos los días a ese lugar
donde llegan los desplazados de la
ciudad de stafford y sea llamar la
atención por el futuro de los militares
natalia es una de ellas su marido está
atrapado allí y ella cree que está
herido hace días no tiene contacto con
él
sin esa seña ecuatoriana pasado
el mensaje más potente que recibí de él
decía que nunca tuvo un deseo tan fuerte
de sobrevivir como hasta ahora por eso
están resistiendo agarrándose a la
mínima posibilidad de sobrevivir quieren
salvarse a toda costa se misión en
basilea ni medida cal dudas más densa
castro saben que por eso quiero mandar
mi mensaje a los líderes de los
gobiernos para que nos ayuden a
salvarnos y sacarlos vivos no importa en
qué condiciones van y por macri diciendo
ya tuna
hoy se conocerá así esta misión de las
naciones unidas y de la cruz roja que va
camino a mariupol a rescatar al menos
esos 200 civiles especialmente mujeres y
niños que están allí atrapados tienen
éxito no es una misión fácil como no lo
fue la que sucedió esta semana donde al
menos 150 personas pudieron ser
evacuadas de allí el trayecto para
llegar hasta policía es bastante duro
como nos han contado muchísimos retenes
rusos muchísimos problemas así que los
ojos de los ucranianos están en lo que
pueda pasar en esa ciudad costera del
mar de azov de mariupol y con lo que
pasa con estas personas y militares que
están allí atrapados
precisamente el ministro de exteriores
de ucrania declaró también que su país
desea que se establezca un tribunal de
justicia especial que persiga la
agresión y otras violaciones del derecho
internacional rusas dmitro culeba
aseguró que esta es una petición que
tiene apoyo internacional y que un
tribunal de este tipo vendría a llenar
el vacío que deja el hecho que ninguna
jurisdicción se encarga de perseguir el
delito de agresión
durante dos meses y medio el ejército
ruso ha cometido numerosos crímenes de
lesa humanidad al atacar
indiscriminadamente a civiles violar
repetidamente el derecho internacional
humanitario y cometer numerosos crímenes
de guerra números warcraft
más a través las masacres en busca ir
pino josh homme el oro dianca y el
desastre humanitario de mariupol
requieren una pronta respuesta legal de
la comunidad internacional
unity en un nuevo informe publicado este
viernes la ong amnistía internacional
afirmó tener pruebas de una serie de
crímenes de guerra cometidos por las
fuerzas rusas en la región al noroeste
de que entre febrero y marzo entre ellos
ataques aéreos ilegales en boro dianca y
ejecuciones extrajudiciales en bucha por
su parte la onu ha aumentado al menos
tres mil 309 los civiles muertos desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa mientras
que otros tres mil 493 habrían resultado
heridos para analizar esta información
hablamos con erika guevara rosas
directora para las américas de amnistía
internacional
erika guevara bienvenida a france 24 su
organización denuncia ataques ilegítimos
y homicidios deliberados rusos en
ucrania como se ha elaborado este
informe
bueno durante 12 días de investigación
con nuestros equipos de crisis en una
delegación que hoy día se encuentra
liderada por nuestra secretaria general
áñez calama no hemos podido recolectar
los solo testimonio de personas víctimas
de familiares de víctimas de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y de otros graves
crímenes en las localidades en donde
hemos visitado además de recolectar
material de prueba de evidencia incluido
material balístico en situaciones en
donde consideramos se han cometido
crímenes de guerra como ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y ataques
indiscriminados en contra de la
población civil a través de estos
ataques aéreos sí como ya hemos dicho en
este informativo el ministro de
exteriores de ucrania declaró que su
país desea que se establezca un tribunal
de justicia especial para que persiga la
agresión y otras violaciones del derecho
internacional cree que esta sería una
alternativa viable y si no cómo pueden
ser juzgados estos hechos
bueno nosotros hacemos un llamado a la
comunidad internacional con esta
evidencia que hemos podido recolectar de
estos crímenes de guerra de estos
homicidios ilegítimos de estas
ejecuciones extrajudiciales
precisamente para que sea a través de
los mecanismos establecidos como la
propia corte penal internacional que
pueda conocer de los hechos para
garantizar los derechos a la verdad y la
justicia de las víctimas de miles de
víctimas que lamentablemente están
siendo sometidas a estas atrocidades por
más de 70 días ya si los hechos que
denuncian en su informe son puntuales o
por el contrario puede hablarse de un
patrón generalizado en esta guerra
bueno sin lugar a duda estamos viendo un
patrón generalizado hasta ahora no
podemos contar con evidencia para hablar
de una política deliberada de órdenes al
más alto nivel pero sin lugar a dudas
nos estamos encontrando con un patrón
común son ya 70 días en donde se han
denunciado estos crímenes de guerra que
no para continúan los ataques
deliberados en contra de población civil
y en ese sentido es importantísimo por
ello que se hagan estas investigaciones
internacionales y brevemente existe
también algún tipo de evidencia que por
parte del ejército ucraniano se hayan
cometido también actos similares
amnistía internacional sigue
investigando de hecho hemos recibido
información audiovisual estos vídeos que
se han preparado
efectivamente de ejecuciones que se
hacen por parte de las fuerzas
ucranianas
pues son dan los rusos que han sido
detenidos seguimos verificando la
información pero cabe señalar que
amnistía internacional no ha podido
ingresar a territorios o canales 5
ucranianos que han sido tomados por el
ejército ruso precisamente porque no se
nos permite el acceso así es que ha sido
imposible poder verificar este tipo de
material erika guevara muchas gracias
por atendernos en france 24
seguimos gracias gracias erika seguimos
ahora en madrid la capital española
donde otra explosión de un edificio en
el conocido barrio de salamanca dejó al
menos dos muertos y 18 heridos en lo que
se cree haya podido ser una explosión
por un escape de gas según la principal
hipótesis que manejan por ahora las
autoridades según informaron también los
bomberos de madrid los dos fallecidos
serían dos obreros que se encontraban
realizando unos trabajos de fontanería
en el tercer piso del edificio ya
quienes en un principio se había dado
por desaparecidos entre los escombros
y el consejo nacional del partido
socialista francés ratificó a primera
hora del viernes un acuerdo de coalición
con otros tres partidos de izquierda
para concurrir como frente unido a las
próximas elecciones parlamentarias de
junio el debate sobre la propuesta duró
cuatro horas y se saldó con la adhesión
a la francia insumisa los verdes y el
partido comunista a todos ellos partidos
que fueron desunidos a las últimas
elecciones presidenciales
el acuerdo su oficial el partido
socialista francés ratificó una alianza
de coalición de izquierdas que espera
desafiar al presidente emmanuel manjón
en las elecciones parlamentarias de
junio tras horas de debates a veces
tensos una amplia mayoría de los
miembros del consejo votaron a favor
vamos a tener que avanzar a partir de
ahora jean-luc mélenchon ha asumido una
gran responsabilidad de esta noche ahora
es la única esperanza para la izquierda
y los ecologistas
jean-luc mélenchon que ha perdido en la
primera vuelta de las presidenciales de
abril busca la mayoría de los diputados
los socialistas en los verdes en los
comunistas y el partido la francia
insumisa de milán son calificaron el
acuerdo como histórico pero no todo el
mundo está satisfecho aún con divisiones
en el seno del partido socialista mucho
socialista soy socialista y el liderazgo
ligado a la insumisa no cambiará de
sochi de nuevo del socialismo el ex
presidente francés françois hollande
también ha manifestado su firme
oposición al acuerdo al igual que las
elecciones en ciales los comicios
legislativos en las 577
circunscripciones de francia funcionan
con un sistema de dos vueltas lo que
significa que las alianzas ofrecen unas
mejores posibilidades de llegar a la
segunda ronda la cohabitación forzada
entre maicon y mélenchon sería la
primera en dos décadas aunque los
expertos ven ese escenario como poco
probable
sri lanka declaró el estado de
emergencia luego que miles de ciudadanos
fueran a la huelga este viernes para
exigir al presidente y al gobierno que
renuncien para asumir la responsabilidad
de la peor crisis financiera de la isla
en décadas desde el jueves cientos de
estudiantes acampan frente a la
carretera principal del parlamento el
país vive golpeado por la pandemia y el
aumento del precio del combustible y la
falta de alimentos además de los
recortes fiscales del gobierno
[Aplausos]
cerramos con noticias del cob y 19 en
china porque el país asiático extrema
medidas ante los nuevos casos de
coronavirus beijing cerró varias
estaciones de tren y continúan las
pruebas masivas la comisión nacional de
sanidad anunció hoy 12 nuevas muertes a
causa del cob y 19 y la detección de
374 nuevos positivos todos los
fallecimientos se registraron en
shanghai convertida desde hace un mes en
el epicentro de los rebrotes en el país
asiático
hasta aquí este repaso de la actualidad
internacional sigan conectados a france
24 y recuerden que pueden ampliar toda
esta hay mucha más información en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]